last night we exposed Democrats growing
distrust of democracy especially of
voters in red state America home
liberals view with total and utter
contempt
well socialism is a hard sell in flyover
country it's one of the reasons
Elizabeth Warren chokes every time she's
asked whether Medicare for all will
raise taxes on the middle class because
she knows it will direct question will
middle-class taxes go up to pay for the
program but what families have to deal
with is cost total cost that's what they
have to deal are we gonna pay for it are
you gonna raise the middle class taxes
costs are going to go up for the
wealthiest Americans for big corporation
taxes was William Acosta and
hard-working middle-class families are
going to see their costs go down
Democrats know their policies are not
going to lead to a stronger economy
certainly is not gonna be stronger than
Trump's they don't even bother trying to
make that case anymore instead they find
themselves reverting to the old Hillary
Clinton playbook in other words if you
aren't confident you can win on the
merits undermine the process and if you
lose don't accept the outcome is
legitimate work to undermine its
legitimacy by any means necessary there
are four key facts that demonstrate how
the Democrats used foreign powers deep
state actors and targeted leaks to
tamper with the election of 2016 and
they're not finished yet fact number one
in April of 2016
it was the Hillary Clinton campaign in
the DNC that hired fusion GPS which
funded the research in that phony
dossier they relied on a British spy a
foreign agent Christopher Steele to
compile what they considered damaging
information on Donald Trump in his
campaign much of it of course unverified
and ultimately discredited but that
didn't matter to them at chrissteele
dossier says that Cohen was integrally
involved in interacting with Russians in
that election interference effort and
trying to
go back to the frickin fracking
Christopher steel dossier how was Russia
reportedly trying to compromise and
cultivate Donald Trump for years by
offering him lucrative real estate deals
first of all there's the question of
whether there's the tape that exists
that was brought up in the steel dossier
which is by the way looking better and
better well they passed the allegations
along to powerful anti Trump interests
in the government from John McCain to
the FBI and sought to open up an
investigation of any and all figures
near candidate Trump what did someone
once call it an insurance policy that's
right fact number two the Democrats use
the FBI and the Obama DOJ to peddle the
foreign source dossier to the FISA Court
to secure warrants against Trump's
advisers like Carter page former FBI
director Jim Comey and his deputy Andrew
McCabe tripped over themselves running
to the FISA Court that ultimately
permitted them to surveil American
citizens and then the same deep state
actors started leaking info to friendly
media we've had reporting in recent
months that George papadopolis was
involved in trying to set up meetings
with Russian government officials
including Vladimir Putin for candidate
Donald Trump we know Carter page was
considered by the FBI to be potentially
a knowing Russian agent you could see
why the Moller inquiry might be looking
for communications related to them ooh
fact number three Democrats used foreign
agents to do their dirty work in 2016
well do you remember how George
papadopolis a low-level Trump volunteer
got roped into this entire drama in
April of 2016 he had a conversation with
this man Joseph Miss Foote a professor
from Malta with long-standing ties to
the State Department
the good professor tried to tempt
Papadopoulos claiming that the Russians
had dirt on Hillary well not exactly a
political sophisticate Papadopoulos then
repeated that information to this man
former Australian ambassador Alexander
Downer stay with me here
now according to reports the meeting
with downer was set up by people
Papadopoulos didn't even know happen
appleís later accused owner of recording
their conversations how convenient and
somehow those conversation made their
way to the deep state channels and
became the predicate for the entire
investigation into Team Trump and it all
happened courtesy of two foreign actors
an all saucy and a Maltese we're not
talking about a cute puppy
but now the Democrats they're telling us
they're worried about foreign intrusion
in elections fact number four when the
Muller probe fizzled Democrats needed to
back up and quick and they thought they
found it Democrats prayed and hoped that
Robert Muller would unearth something
anything to justify the impeachment of
Donald Trump well basically found
nothing I have to say that far from
breathing life into the report he kind
of sucked the life out a report out of
the report I was struck by the enormous
personal contrast between robert muller
and donald trump I think he's out of
legal jeopardy I hate to say it and
you're are putting my blood vessels at
risk but I think my my hunch is he has
gotten away with it which brings us to
the present the Democrats know the
Department of Justice is actively
investigating the deep state smashing
nations in 2016 and the role played by
the foreign actors we've just told you
about they will do anything to destroy
not only the president but Attorney
General Bill Bar and the State
Department on the brink of uncovering
their election tampering
I thought Pompey was just an ambitious
guy now I'm finding out he'd like
William Barr our trumpian one would
think with all that's going on bill a
barb I don't to sound sassy but
globe-trotting on an issue that's highly
personal to the president doesn't really
seem like the job function of the
Attorney General it seems like I don't
know someone from Trump's 20/20
re-election campaign bingo now what the
media is missing
in the much-discussed call with the
Ukrainian president is that Trump
requested Ukraine's cooperation to
investigate not only wrongdoing by the
Biden's but the entire deep state as
well in other words he's working the
president's working to uncover election
meddling I thought that's what the
Democrats wanted just today The Daily
Beast reports that Barre traveled to
Rome to listen to a secret recording of
a deposition by Professor Mifsud the
Attorney General is clearly closing in
on the foreign players from 2016 come on
this all explains why the Democrats are
freaking out and they are so determined
to stop Trump and smear Barr they've bet
I think that it's safer to sully Trump
with bogus accusations then finally face
the music themselves a true
investigation of their actions to
interfere in a presidential election
using foreign actors phony information
and a complicit deep State and that's
the angle